so we met on Smallville I remember you
played my brother yeah Lucas right yeah
it's kind of crazy to me that I played
your brother and I was only on for one
episode yeah I thought you were gonna
come back and then they just left that
story I think you complained about that
in the episode you're like why did and
now he's gone you know at some place but
you know what's weird is like when I
when I originally got that part if
memory serves it's been like two decades
it was supposed to be multi-episode Arc
and I don't know if I just did a shitty
job and they were just like oh let's
stop bringing it back but I I think I
did a pretty good job right so I was
surprised I don't know what happened but
for whatever reason that was it I but I
we talk about this all the time here's
here the trend was in the first couple
Seasons until they got it together
um is that every show unlike today the
streamers that have Cliff hangers and we
keep they wrap everything up in a nice
bow right and moving on right and it
just irked me right and so that was the
way it wasn't evolved and now we've
evolved into this right um but do you
remember anything
at all on that show
oh God because you worked with me you
worked with John Glover who was like our
father that's right yeah and then I I do
remember the director and I remember who
was it uh Beeman Greg Beaman Greg Beeman
and I remember the scene where uh there
was a rain Tower and uh something
happened and I you know I I don't know
there was a shootout and then you
grabbed me and you go uh I'm your
brother and for whatever reason there
was a lot of drama not drama there was
like we were really struggling getting
that moment I don't know if it was like
Greg wasn't happy or you weren't happy I
remember it now yeah I remember it I
remember what it was okay and I
complained about it on the show if you
recall we go out and I go I'm your
brother let's go right but I think what
happens is you come with me and then we
stop at the doors of the car when these
guys were shooting us go look I'm your
brother I'm like dude we wouldn't do
that we have to we would go in the car
right right and then we get out of there
and then I'd say that right we can't do
that right off right all right this is
unrealistic Greg he's like you know yeah
I think we'll remember that day
I won't say who it is but one of the
crew guys pissed their pants they just
want to go to the bathroom in one take
and I heard him going oh God God and
he's like [__] and he he laughed he
pissed himself I uh I don't think I was
privy to that as a guess I was I think
this is a series regular pissed him
right off on that thing I think it was
uh you used to do this thing all right
this is what I do remember and you're
gonna be like really that's what you
remember and I stole this from you on my
show good so you used a video not you
used to do this thing where and you
would do this in like like a very
obviously jokey way and everyone loved
it someone would [__] off no no you
would say go [__] yourself like
literally somebody somebody would say
hey Michael can you uh stand on your
mark and be like yeah go [__] yourself
and I just thought it was so funny and
then the crew would do it with me yeah
I'd say hey can you make sure that yeah
[__] yourself let's just yeah right yeah
it was a thing we all did it and I just
thought you do it you did it on vampire
I became known as the go [__] yourself
in fact there was a it's okay yeah
there's uh there's Greg they even as rap
gifts they gave the crew gfy hats from
me which was and you never called me go
[__] yourself hats I literally stole
that from you did you ever tell anybody
nobody told any I never told anyone yeah
I'm on a podcast right now telling the
world that I still go [__] yourself from
you so at least at least I finally you
know it took me some time I'm glad you
did that I remember I remember you
laughing I remember you just I just
thought it was great well I just thought
it was fantastic because I just you know
it's like it just kind of relaxes you
just go [__] yourself uh I would say it
even when I [__] up what's the line
[__] go [__] yourself thanks all right
exactly and it was just it made me kind
of comfortable well it just I think also
and you would know like when you're a
guest star you know when you're a young
guest star and you're coming into this
show that's like nervous you know it's
nerve-wracking it's like a big hit show
and then you know sometimes when you
have the series regulars who take
themselves too seriously you it makes
you even more stressed you don't want to
mess up and then when you have somebody
who's you you know one of the leads on
the show saying go [__] yourself and
everyone's laughing yeah suddenly you're
like okay I can loosen up a little bit
and I can have some fun yeah